tell me about your hand with the police
uh yeah don't tell me your police say
she started um obviously it got worse
and i had to get this the bone taken out
of my hip and put in there
and i got three two screws in there but
now dr michaels did a great job on my
hand and what happened
from that you know it started off with
the
the cops
handcuffed
no the bill the flashlight
boom the flash and a big long flash like
that and my head got eight stitches in
my head
and my hand
but you said i fought myself
you started fighting the gods no i
didn't fight him at all no i was just
dicky was getting arrested
and i went over and they see me going
over and they thought i was gonna do
something but i wasn't they grabbed me
and then that was it oh so it was an
accident though
well nerdpie not mine
no it wasn't an accident
no because you're right a cop doesn't
know what you know what i'm saying and
then i've seen the and the funny thing
is i've seen a couple years later mike
listen the cops know who everybody is
they know they they had trouble with
dicky before oh 100
that's why they grabbed him because he
was getting in trouble all the time
some cops don't like people they're
human beings some people irritate stuff
you know he was getting a lot of trouble
then whatever and i don't know it's just
one of those things i was in the wrong
place at the right time i guess
i can i can only imagine
those flashlights are like six pounds
they're heavy maybe 10. yeah
they want to hit me in the head
well i didn't get dazed me but if
everything went cold
there's like ice on my head
yeah okay
you got a lawsuit against these guys no
i didn't do it now
yeah yeah i didn't wanna yeah it wasn't
worth it
yeah you you've been you've been able to
have your but that was cool i'm cool
with them all now i get along with them
all now i was just
you know like the guy that did i seen
him years later and i said listen if i
if you thought i was going to do
something i never was going to do
anything i said but
you know
you know i just you know i hold no
grudge whatever you know i don't want to
deal with that for the rest of my life
you know i mean that ain't whatever
he says mickey thank you so much for
doing that you're more of a man to me
and you know the guy's all right he was
just in a bad predicament yeah you talk
about the cops yeah then that's that's
crazy what are you gonna do yeah you
know i mean it's over
you can't bring it back yeah
don't let it don't let your path dictate
your future right
you